I have my powers to protect me
promise me we do this together okay hey
Elsa we loved everything about frozen -
your journey was epic and super
surprising we never could have imagined
a better ending at first you promised
Anna that you wouldn't shut her out but
then out of nowhere you sent on and all
up away in an ice canoe you didn't want
to put on in danger so you pushed her
away luckily on and knew exactly what to
do to save the day as it turns out your
little sister doesn't need powers to be
powerful
so Elsa now that you have your freedom
what are you going to do with it by the
end of frozen - things would never be
the same for the daughters of the late
king Agner and queen i Doudna Elsa is
finally living the life she always
dreamed of and Anna is serving her
people as the queen of arendelle
we know how Anna will be spending her
time but what about Elsa keep watching
to find out oh how I wish this could
last forever honest coronation we
weren't the only ones who noticed that
Elsa didn't attend Ana's coronation
a lot of fans found Elsa's absence to be
unusual considering how close the two
sisters are but we think that Elsa just
wasn't ready to leave the enchanted
forest
and since Ana's coronation must have
happened immediately after the sisters
saved arendelle we can see why Elsa
didn't want to attend Elsa may no longer
be queen but as the new leader of the
Enchanted Forest
she still has duties of her own so she
probably stayed back to help the North
aldrin settle into their new roles or
maybe also wanted Ana's coronation to be
about Anna and not herself Elsa will
master her powers on top of settling
into her new role as the protector of
the enchanted forest Elsa will also
spend her time mastering her powers
being the only magical person in
arendelle took a toll on Elsa she
couldn't put her powers to the test
because it could freak people out and it
was dangerous too
but in the forest also is free to use
her powers at will and the people of the
North Ultra tribe love magic and aren't
scared of it
Elsa will spend most of her time
stepping into her power and using it to
create beauty as the bridge between the
four elements Elsa can also use the
other spirits powers to heighten her own
so she has a lot of material to cover
Elsa is basically a freshman in power
school also will make new friends unlike
Anna Elsa hasn't always been a social
person at heart and that had everything
to do with her environment I think you
should go
the party is over close the game now
that Elsa is free to be herself she's
going to make a lot of new friends in
the forest Elsa will probably spend a
lot of time with yelena learning the
secrets of the north aldrin tribe she
might even dig into the past to find out
everything there is to know about her
mother who came from a well-known North
aldrin family on top of befriended Bruni
NOK Gale and the earth Giants Elsa will
also spend a lot of time with her new
best friends honey Marin and Ryder
keep watching to find out if love is on
the horizon for the former queen of
arendelle history class Elsa and Anna
didn't get to know their parents all
that much they didn't know about.i Dunas
past or where their parents were headed
the night their ship capsized thankfully
as Olaf pointed out water has memory the
water that makes up you and me has
passed through at least four animals
before us so Elsa can get to know her
mother and father a whole lot better by
sifting through the memories in at toe
Holland I also will spend a lot of her
free time in the river full of memory as
the protector of the enchanted forest
Elsa needs to learn everything about it
this way she'll know how to keep it safe
Elsa will spend her formative years
studying the history of the forest
settling down somewhere down the line
Elsa is going to fall in love and settle
down now that she has journeyed into the
unknown and accepted her true selves
she can finally be in a healthy
relationship we love the new characters
in frozen too and would be happy if I so
wound up with either honey Marin or
writer writer is bound to become
Christoph's best friend no offense spend
and we'd love to see on a Kristoff Elsa
and Ryder go on weekly double dates but
a lot of people think that Elsa belongs
with honey Marian because well there was
plenty of chemistry between the two of
them if you love catching up on the
latest Disney Series hit that big red
subscribe button so you never miss
another video click that bell to get
notified as soon as we upload a new one
here at the things we post fun videos
about your favorite movies TV shows and
characters every single day if you're
watching on your mobile go on YouTube
settings and turn on notifications and
that's a wrap on what happens to Elsa
after frozen - if you could choose
Elsa's romantic partner who would it be
and wide tell us in the comments before
you go don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching the
things we'll see you next time
[Music]